hey this is press to
Walker what is the value of the
following infinite Series S is equal to
1 2 over 2 ^ 1 + 2^ 2 over 2 ^ 2 + 3^ 2
over 2 ^ 3 + 4^ 2 over 2 ^ 4 and so on
where the general term is n^ 2/ 2 the^
of n what is the value of s PA pause the
video if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem the first thing we'll do is
we'll check for convergence of this
series so that we know it's a convergent
series then we can do the normal
manipulation we do like multiplying and
subtracting series from each other we
won't run into any problems where we're
subtracting Infinity from
Infinity so we will use the ratio test
we take the limit as n goes to Infinity
of the absolute value of the ratio of
consecutive
terms we substitute in and now we're
going to
simplify so this works out to be 12
multiplied the square of n + 1 / n we
then simplify the fraction and then
simplify the limit so this is equal to
12 * 1^2 which equal 12 Which is less
than one so we have a convergent
series the first method we'll use to
solve the problem is Define a
pattern we have this sum now let's just
write each of the square terms
out now let's multiply this entire
series by two term by term we can do
this because we know we have a
convergent
series now let's line up the
denominators we'll subtract the top
equation from the second equation term
by term so we have 2 s- s which is equal
to S and this is equal to 1 + 3 over 2 +
5 over 4 + 7 over 8 + 9 over 16 and so
on now we will subtract one from this
series and then again we will multiply
by
two we will take this series and we will
subtract the one that's right above it
so we have 2 of s -1 - s is equal to 2 +
2 over 2 + 2 over 4 + 2 8 and so on so
this simplifies that s - 2 is equal to 2
+ 1 +2 + 1 over 4 + 1 over 8 and so on
and now we have something that we can
solve very
easily 1 +2 + 1 over4 + 1 over8 and so
on is a standard geometric series with a
common ratio of 1/2 and a the first term
of 1 so s - 2 is equal to 2 + 1 over 1
-2 and that equals 2 + 2 this means s is
equal to 6 and that's one way to solve
the
problem now another way is to consider
sequences so we have this term SN we'll
look at the sum up to the nth
term we can write this in summation form
that this is a sum from n = 1 to
Infinity of n ^2 / 2 ^ n now we can
reindex this going from n = 0 if we have
n + 1^ 2 over 2 ^ of n +
1 now since n equals 0 will be a term
that's equal to zero we can also reindex
this from Nal 0 to Infinity of n^2 / 2 ^
of n these are all just different ways
of writing the same
sum now from here we're going to take
this summation minus this summation in
fact we will take two times the blue
summation so the sum is equal to 2 * the
blue summation minus the green summation
that's of course equal to the original
summation so now we have two times the
blue summation minus the green summation
so let's simplify
this the two will cancel out in the
denominator so now we have 2 the^ of n
in both
denominators we can group The summation
and then we have a common denominator so
we group this all together in one
fraction we can now simplify the
numerator we expand the binomial and
then cancel out the N squ terms so we
have the sum from n equal 0 to Infinity
of 2 n + 1 all over 2 ^ of n we split
this apart and then we will split this
apart into two different
summations so we have 2 * the sum from n
equal 0 to Infinity of n / 2 the N plus
the sum of 1 over 2 the N from Nal 0 to
Infinity now the second summation is
easy to recognize this is the sum of a
geometric series with the common ratio
of 1/2 and the first term of 1 so this
is equal to 1 / 1 -2 which is equal to
2 now what about the other summation n /
2^ of n this is an arithmetical
geometric Series so here's how it's
written out 1/ 2 + 2 over 4 + 3 8 + 4 16
and so on so here's one way that we can
solve this we know we have one term of
1/2 we then have two terms of 1 over4
and we'll stack them on top of each
other we then have three terms of 1
over8 which will stack on top of each
other then we have four terms of 1 over
16 so we're going to continue this
pattern and we're going to create like a
triangular
shape the very first line is a geometric
series starting with 1/2 in a common
ratio of 1 over4 so we know this is
equal to 1 the second is a geometric
series that starts at 1 over 4 or it's
the first line minus 1/2 either way you
can get it's equal to 1 over two the
next one we subtract 1 over4 or we have
a geometric series starting with 1 over8
so this is equal to 1 over4 then we
subtract 1 over8 to get 1
over8 so we can see each of these lines
is a geometric series and in the end if
we sum all these together we're going to
end up with another geometric series we
have 1 + 1 12+ 1 over 4 + 1 over 8 and
so on so the sum of all of these is
equal to two we now substitute in so s
is equal 2 * 2 + 2 and that gives us the
answer answer of
six so now here's a third way to solve
it using a generating function suppose
the absolute value of x is less than 1
and say f ofx is equal to 1 + x + x^2 +
x cub and so on we have a geometric
series with a first term of one and a
common ratio of X so this sum is equal
to 1 / 1 -
x now let's differentiate term by term 1
becomes z x becomes 1 X x^2 becomes 2X x
Cub becomes 3x^2 and so on so then we
can differentiate 1 / 1 - x and that's
equal to 1 / the sare of 1 -
x we will multiply both sides of this
equation by
X then we are going to take the
derivative of
this so we differentiate term by term so
we get 1 + 4x + 9 x^2 and so on then we
have to differ differentiate x / 1 - x
so we use the quotient
rule we simplify this so we get the
derivative is equal to 1 + x / the cube
of 1 - x we're almost
there let's take this entire series and
multiply it by X so we have x + 4x^2 + 9
x cub and so on and that's equal to x *
1 + x all over the Cub of 1 - x we just
substitute X Asal to 12 and that exactly
gives us the series s that we want so we
substitute on the right hand side and we
just need to simplify this so we get
that s is equal to 6 and that's a final
way to solve this
question thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh